alors avec vous frédéric peut-être qu'on
peut rappeler un peu d'abord ce projet
d'université francophones ça devait être
construit enfin ouvert à toronto
ça a été un symbole très important très
important évidemment est donc en 2020 on
espère y accueillir pas moins de trois
cent quarante huit étudiants et
graduellement on allait grossir la ce
contingent donc on arrivait à 1000
étudiants en 2023 pour atteindre
finalement en 2028 un rythme de
croisière qui était de 2000 étudiants
d'où serait-il venu d'où elle sort est
il venu cette population il ya eu 44 %
d'adultes de plus de 25 ans et fait
intéressant il y aurait eu 46 %
d'étudiants qui auraient été recrutés à
l'étranger
il y avait un budget d'ailleurs qui
avait été mis sur la table on avait
tablé sur 83 millions et demi de dollars
qui auraient été ventilés comme suit
c'est à dire on aurait eu des
rénovations à faire dans un bâtiment du
collège boréal de 12 millions de dollars
et il y avait un budget de
fonctionnement répartis sur 7 ans qui
dépassait un peu 71 millions de dollars
mais des programmes de formation en
français y en existe quand même atteint
en ontario oui il y en existe
effectivement en fait il ya onze
établissements qui en offre d'abord il
ya des collèges le collège boréal par
exemple ou encore la cité dans la région
d'ottawa dans le nord de l'ontario on
avait la laurentienne on avait
l'université de sudbury université de
rust et plus on allait vers le sud
on est bien sûr le collège royal
militaire on à l'université d'ottawa
il y avait par exemple aussi le collège
universitaire dominicain l'université de
toronto et le collège glendon sur le
campus de l'université de york mais
encore là c'est très local et c'est très
ciblée conformation et ailleurs au pays
question qu'est ce qui existe pour les
francophones donc si on ajoute ce qui
est offert en ontario on arrive à peu
près à 1200 programmes offerts mais pas
juste francophone on parle aussi de
programmes bilingues est important de
faire la différenciation sinon vous avez
donc 21 institutions qui en offrait par
exemple vous avez l'université
sainte-anne en nouvelle écosse il ya
trois universités dans la région de
moncton donc évidemment trois campus
différents 11 ans l'ontario l'université
saint boniface évidemment la plus
ancienne université francophone à
l'ouest de toronto ensuite mais vous
aviez par exemple à gravelbourg en
saskatchewan à regina en alberta ou
encore deux institutions ici en colombie
britannique comme le collège et du cac
centre ou encore le but
des affaires francophones de
l'université simon-fraser et encore une
fois si on compare avec ce qui se donne
ici au québec à l'autre minorité c'est à
dire les anglophones eux ils les ont
trois universités qui offre un éventail
très très large justement la formation
ce qui n'est pas le cas ailleurs au
canada pour les francophones qui eux
doivent aller dans des endroits très
précis et ce sont des formations qui
sont très partiellement les programmes
assez limité en fait tout à fait merci
beaucoup